Tony Dungy in the Continental Tire
Coaches Corner coach are you asked more
about the Super Bowl matchup or the
controversial play in New Orleans and I
guess that's a good thing about football
then it has everybody's passion and you
know I feel the pain of the the Saints
players and their coaches and their fans
but that's football and I hope we don't
overreact to this there's bad calls
you know 1972 people from Oakland still
tell me it's French Dip fuqua the ball
hit him and then I'm in this you know
University of Minnesota watching the
Vikings and Dallas and I still believe
Drew Pearson twist-off and it was bad
call it happens it's 40 years ago okay
and some some of this you just have to
let it go but we can't overreact and
start saying we want to replay
everything and you want to go to court
when the call doesn't go our way I just
I can't buy that do you think there's
any changes in the offseason
whether it's plays like this in the last
two minutes where you'd get a challenge
flag you could use or is there a change
to overtime with the competition
committee I don't I think no on either
one because in the last two minutes
most things are reviewed anyway if you
start bringing judgment calls into it
what's past interference what's holding
was before it really all side or was he
just close let's take a look at that you
know you're opening up Pandora's box
now what what change I hope they do make
and what I would recommend is going to
full-time official and let's get some
consistency over the whole game not just
one call here there but I think that's
the change we need to look at not
looking at reviewing one call and they
overtime I'm fine with that as the
defensive coach you got to stop them
okay and if we made the change to a
field goal so they can't just have two
first downs and kick a 50-yard field
goal to win but but somewhere along the
line you got to get a stop and get the
ball back for your offense
yeah I'm there with you on both of these
I don't want to overreact it was a bad
call
over time I'm fine I think overtime
worked I think people have a problem
with over time because the Patriots took
advantage of it and Brady led them down
whereas the Rams played defense force
the interception and then kick the field
goal
yeah but the classic classic example
three third and ten and they didn't stop
any one of them and New England won the
long yardage situation the Rams fold up
caused an interception and were able to
win the game so both teams that I'm also
curious about this though tone if you
know you had an official who was right
there on the spot in New Orleans with
this play but we've seen plays before
where three officials throw a flag on
the same play for the same penalty I'm I
was shocked that nobody got together and
said hey guy hey let me let's just talk
about this here because what I saw is
like wouldn't you want to help protect
that official or is it their egos are at
stake and nobody wants to point out
something or say you just missed it and
you're right in front of that play no
that's the problem that no one talks
about and it's these all-star curves and
people who haven't worked with each
other that was the normal crew you know
I said I'm sure that would have happened
someone that back judge decide says
somebody would have thrown the flag and
said hey you didn't see it but I saw it
that's passing offense but let's put the
ball here but you know it doesn't always
work that way and then the other thing I
think we've got to get away from in the
playoffs is they don't want to call
thing you know and and they don't want
to be the deciding factor but if it's a
penalty in the first quarter it's a
company in the fourth quarter if it's a
penalty in the preseason game it's a
tunnel in the playoffs and we've got to
get back to just calling the game as it
is and not saying well you know TV
doesn't want penalties we don't want
games stop it so let things go in the
playoffs talking to Tony Dungy NBC
football night in America analysts and
of course Hall of Fame coach can Bill
Belichick be out coached
I wouldn't say our coat but you know
certainly schemes good to come up and
happen and you know it just look at this
last game day and the Patriots do what
they always do they had a different game
plan all sensibly and defense in Kansas
City wasn't ready for it they got the
lead 14 nothing Andy Reid and his staff
made some great adjustments and they
scored 31 points in the second half Tom
Brady throws the ball just a little bit
high off for Gronkowski's hands and it's
intercepted
if D for it isn't lined up offsides then
would say all wah Andy Reed did a great
job of adjusting look at that 31 points
in the second half while with that
masterful their different narrative so
yes I mean everybody makes adjustments I
think that's going to be what's going to
be on cell McVeigh's plate he's not sure
what type of defense they're going to
run what they're going to do to take
things away he's going to have to just I
see New England getting off to us a lead
in this game and then how quick does the
RAM staff adjust and what did they do
and tend to come back in the second half
play out but also I I was looking at
teams that give the Patriots trouble or
you can beat the Patriots in a big game
and I go back to the Ravens had a great
front the Giants had a great front and
the Rams have a great front and I think
that that's the key if you put pressure
up the middle on Brady then you know
then it's different Kansas City for nine
years
and what does he always say you've got a
rust inside you got a pressure Brady
without blitzing and you've got to play
tight man-to-man cards you've got a bump
those receivers and not let Tom have the
easy quick blows Baltimore you're right
was able to do that they had its
physical secondary they had great rush
the Giants and the two Super Bowls had
that the Rams have that now can they do
it for four quarters and they do it in
the big game cannon Dominick and Cruz
show up because Bill Belichick is not
going to let Aaron Donald wreck the game
so and I'm consumed is going to do one
on one block
and an Erin Donald is not I can promise
you that it does better where they put
them and Donald is going to get blocked
by two people
so Tim to show up and Dante Fowler show
up can they press it without blitzing
and can those coverage that hold up and
again it's going to come down to how do
they call again because we know Marcus
Peters and a key to leave are going to
press the rules and they're going to
grab and they're going to be there on a
bum permit six yards and seven yards is
that gonna get called well we'll see
did it bring back memories when you're
watching Brady there and over time where
he's just you know it almost felt like a
foregone conclusion that he was somehow
going to get them at least in field goal
range if not scored touchdown but as a
former coach going against him you've
seen this before you bring it and you
have to get you've got to make a play
you've got to get a sack fumble you've
got to get a turnover when they got it
they got it but just you know that's the
one thing I admire about the Patriots
they do not beat themselves they do not
make those type of mistakes so when you
do get that sack or get that turnover
tip ball and you line up all sides at
that point I knew the game was over
yeah are you made up your mind on Jared
Goff like do you know what kind of
quarterback he's going to be in his
career I think he's gonna be very good
but these these are big games now he did
a good job down the stretch in New
Orleans but but we've seen him in some
big games not play that that well so you
know this is gonna be a little bit of a
defining moment early you're clean
against Tom Brady you're playing against
one of the best defensive schemes Brian
Flores Bill Belichick they'll have some
different things and you're going to
have to score a point you know you're
not going to win this game 17 to 10 so
there is a lot of pressure on Jared I
think he's improving his plan well Sean
McVeigh I was out there last year when
we had the playoff game those guys
believe in sugar golf they think
she's gonna be great they think he's the
leader they need so it's uh this would
be a big moment for good to busy with
you Tony's always enjoy the Super Bowl
and thanks for joining us
always I'm going to try to see you
somewhere I think where Paulie do we
have a disclosed location yet we'll give
it to coach off-air Oh oh yeah right now
yeah we're secretive we're like the
Patriots Tony we're very secretive
didn't that Bill Belichick thing on yeah
I like it but no I will come find you
and definitely love to visit with you
next week that would be great I will say
this I'll give you a hint
we are right next door to the Patriots
practice facility Thank You tone see in
Atlanta that's Tony Dungy NBC football
night America for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]